mélanie poquet nous a rejoint le plateau
d'on soir ça alors les cérémonies de
voeux continue sur saint quentin en
yvelines vendredi soir c'était au tour
de grégory à gary astier de s'adresser à
ses administrés le maire de maurepas a
notamment choisi de rapprocher la ville
de l'emploi et des commerces
eh oui maurepas et coignard ont été
retenus grâce au soutien de saint
quentin en yvelines pour restructurer la
zone d'activités paris-ouest forum du jv
et porte de chevreuse il s'agira de
trouver des complémentarités entre ces
zones où des logements vont être
construits mais je laisse grégory gary
astier nous expliquer concrètement
l'état va nous aider financièrement
hauteur de 60 mille euros à financer un
assistant à maîtrise d'ouvragé qui va
nous faire des scénarios opérationnels
pour calibrer dans le futur ce que sera
ce futur ensemble de la zone d'activités
paris ouest avec une partie de
coignières l'objectif c'est de trouver
davantage d'articulation de cohérence
d'intégrer davantage de logements et
aussi de traiter une partie de la zone
sûrement pas qui est moribonde
aujourd'hui et grégory christ a donné
aussi d'autres grandes lignes autour de
l'urbanisme
et oui vendredi soir grégory le maire a
annoncé aussi que le nouveau plan local
d'urbanisme serait votée avant l'été
pour préserver les organes de
l'urbanisation le village et ses terres
agricoles pas moins de 1000 logements
seront construits dans les quatre ans à
venir
et c'était l'une des toutes premières
annonces de cette soirée
le centre nautique d'elancourt morte par
ouvrira en 2021
rappelons que le site a été fermé en
avril 2015
grégory guéris s'ils avaient alors pris
à cette époque un arrêté municipal
d'urgence la déconstruction du site
actuel débutera cette année
merci mélanie on continuera dans ce
journal de faire d'autres pans sur les
cérémonies de voeux qui se déroule dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines